Die zwei Sprechstunden.
I-I-I-I-D-I-I-X-C-D-I-I-I-I-D-I-I-X-C-D-I-X-C-D-I-X-C-D-I-X-C-D-I-
Darüber gibt es mehrere Geschichten, aber die glaubwürdigste ist, dass einer der ersten Flugzeuge, aus denen eine Drohne gebaut wurde, die hieß halt B. Und daraus wurde dann halt die Fire B. Das war ein Zielsystem, also ein Zielsimulationssystem. Und irgendwann kam auf die Idee, naja, wenn es vorher Queen hieß, dann ist die andere Biene dann halt die Drohne.
Die, die man auch wegwerfen kann, die jetzt nur einen Zweck hat.
Genau, die halt nur eine begrenzte Nutzbarkeit hat. Und dann hat sich dieser Begriff Drohne etabliert. Im militärischen Jargon gibt es dann natürlich andere Abkürzungen. Also die fachlich korrekte Bezeichnung ist Unmanned Aerial Vehicle oder Unmanned Aerial Combat Vehicle. Das Combat steht dann dafür, dass es bewaffnet ist.
Da wollte ich gerade fragen, wir haben jetzt die ganze Zeit von Drohnen, also sagen von schon semi-autonom agierenden Kriegsmaschinen geredet, die in der Luft sind. Gibt es nur da Drohnen? Oder gibt es, man könnte sich ja vorstellen, es gab ja auch mal die Legende vom Delfin mit der Sprenggranate, also gibt es auch Unterwasserdrohnen oder Landdrohnen, also Kriegsroboter auf eine andere Art und Weise?
Na es gab diverse Experimente, Tiere fernzusteuern, so auf Cockroaches, wie heißt es auf Kackalaken, haben sie ja auch schon Steuereinheiten drauf gebastelt, um sie dann so links, rechts lang wandern zu lassen. Das funktionierte schon ganz gut. Aber erst mit der Roboter-Technik und vor allem mit der Entwicklung von effizienter Batterietechnik ist jetzt das Entwicklung von wirklich autonomen Landrobotern auch realistischer geworden. Also die DARPA hat da erst vor ein paar Tagen einen neuen Challenge ausgeschrieben, wo sie zweibeinige Roboter einfach zur Verfügung gestellt haben. So ein paar grundsätzliche Routinen funktionieren. Jetzt baut mal daraus Software, die es schafft, einen bestimmten Hindernisparcours zu überwinden. Und dieser Hindernisparcours soll dann Fukushima darstellen, wo so ein Roboter durch die Gegend wandert, hat bestimmte Hindernisüberwindetüren aufmacht und ein Ventil zuschraubt und sich dann wieder daraus tut.
Das hört sich jetzt aber eher nach Supportaufgaben an. Also unterstützend und langsam, hat viel Zeit oder?
Naja, diese muss man vielleicht ein bisschen weiter auswählen. Diese DARPA Challenges sind für die Robotik relativ wichtig. Eine der bekannteren DARPA Challenges war die für autonomes Fahren. Also wo die DARPA gesagt hat, wir müssten noch langsam so weit sein, dass wir Technologie zusammen haben, Autos autonom fahren zu lassen. Die erste war halt ein relatives Desaster, wo halt die meisten Fahrzeuge nicht aus den Startboxen rauskamen. Und was am weitesten kam, kam so 35 Meilen oder so von den geplanten 200. Dann gab es halt zwei weitere Challenges. Am Ende von diesen Challenges fuhren Autos und zwar mehrere, völlig autonom durch eine simulierte Stadt ohne Unfälle zu bauen und haben da halt irgendwie Missionen erfüllt. Und die nächste DARPA Challenge ist halt ein bisschen anders, weil sie sagen, okay, es gibt einen komplizierten Teil dabei, nämlich die Hardware, die machen das selber. Die lassen sie bauen von einem Unternehmen namens Boston Dynamics. Da kann man mal googeln. Die bauen ziemlich abgefahrene Roboter. Also der eine ist der bekanntere davon, das ist der sogenannte Big Dog. Das ist halt so ein vierbeiniger Roboter, der stark so ein bisschen wie so ein Esel durch die Gegend und soll dazu dienen, Soldaten ihre Rucksäcke und Waffen und Munition hinterher zu tragen. Also dass sie die halt nicht selber schleppen müssen, wenn sie durchs Gelände herrschen. Und dann bauen die aber halt auch noch so ein System namens Cheetah, was halt so eine Robkatze ist. Und die sieht dann halt schon wesentlich mehr nach irgendwie Suchen und Töten aus. Also die kann sich halt auch sehr schnell bewegen. Also es rennt sehr schnell. Und sie bauen ein System namens Atlas. Und das ist halt genau dieser Roboter, von dem Edgar es gerade sprach, der für diese DARPA-Challenge verwendet wird. Die nächste DARPA-Challenge, da läuft jetzt gerade die Bewerbungsfrist, wo sich halt Teams bewerben können, darum, dass sie einen von diesen Robotern kriegen, um dann halt sich für diese Challenge die Software zu schreiben. Und da geht es halt darum, dass der Roboter sitzt in einem Raum, geht durch eine Tür aus diesem Raum heraus, kämpft sich durch eine teilweise eingefallene Trümmerwüste, bewegt sich zu einem Fahrzeug, fährt mit diesem Fahrzeug, also einem Traktor oder so, jedenfalls irgendwas, was offen ist, fährt mit diesem Traktor zu einem anderen Gebäude, kämpft sich da wieder durch ein Trümmerfeld zu einer Zielkoordinator und tauscht dann ein Ventil an einem Rohrsystem aus und fährt wieder zurück. Und zwar alles autonom, also ohne, dass sie mehr als die Zielkoordinaten vorgegeben werden, wohin sollen, was er tun soll. Und die rechnen natürlich wieder nicht damit, dass wir am ersten Mal durchkommen, aber zumindest werden wir danach, wenn diese LAPA-Challenges durch sind, Technologie haben mit zweibainigen Robotern, die in der Lage sind, solche Aufgaben zu erfüllen. Und das ist dann schon so verdammt nah an Terminate.
Ich will gerade sagen, wir reden jetzt seit einer Stunde darüber, deswegen hab ich natürlich sofort im Kopf, das Ventil könnte auch eine Handgranate sein.
Genau. Das ist halt so eines der grundlegenden Probleme der Roboterforschung, ist das Auseinanderhalten von so ziviler Forschung und militärisch erwendbarer Forschung ist halt quasi nicht möglich. Also gibt halt, naja, diese typischen zwei Disziplinen der Uni Roboterforschung, das eine ist der sogenannte Roboterfußball, also wo die Roboter halt Fußball spielen, wo man im Wesentlichen halt so Schwarmalgorithmen übt, also dass Roboter eng zusammenarbeiten können. Das andere ist das sogenannte Search and Rescue, was bedeutet, dass Roboter sich in unübersichtlichem Gelände bewegen und da drin Menschen finden, die da verletzt rumliegen oder auch irgendwelche Chemikraienfässer finden, die da irgendwie kaputt rumliegen und die markieren. Und wenn man sich das mal so kurz durch den Kopf gehen lässt, dann ist halt der Unterschied zwischen Search and Rescue und Search and Destroy marginal. Also ob man den Roboter ins Gelände schickt, um da Verletzte zu markieren, damit sie gerettet werden können, oder man ihn da reinschickt, um verborgene Gegner zu erschießen, der Unterschied ist nicht besonders groß. Und das macht eben doch dieses Problem, um mal sozusagen den Bogen so ein bisschen zurückzuspannen zum Eingangspunkt unserer Sendung, nämlich der Verantwortung des Wissenschaftlers, so kompliziert, dass man, wenn man in dem Bereich unterwegs ist und da forscht und entwickelt, dass man sich nie so richtig sicher sein kann, wofür seine Forschungsergebnisse jetzt eigentlich verwendet werden. Also zum Beispiel gerade diese Search-and-Rescue-Thematik, also die Algorithmen zum Beispiel, die benutzt werden, um zu erkennen, ob auf einem Infrarot-Kamera-Bild aus einer Drohne, ob da Menschen sind. Und was die jetzt gerade tun, lässt sich halt sehr vielfältig einsetzen. Kann man verwenden, um verschüttete Nervengebiete zu finden oder kann man verwenden, um illegale Grenzüberquerer zu identifizieren und zu erschießen oder abzufangen. Oder um zu beschließen, dass jetzt irgendwie diese fünf Leute da oben in den Bergen halt irgendwie Taliban sind, weil sie sich zufällig in der falschen Gegend befinden.
Wenn man sich jetzt die Diskussion um den sogenannten Hackerparagrafen anguckt, dann habt ihr ja gesagt, so eine Technologie ist erst mal nicht schuld, sondern das ist halt ein Werkzeug.
Wie seht ihr das in diesem Fall? Im Prinzip gilt es auch da. Man muss sich halt nur überlegen, wie hoch der Preis ist, den man halt willens ist, moragisch zu bezahlen. Dafür, wenn man seine geistige Energie in bestimmte Dinge steckt, wo die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass sie halt missbraucht werden können, möglicherweise höher ist als irgendwie der positive Nutzen, den man bei nicht missbräuchlicher oder nicht kriegerischer Verwendung erzielen kann. Und gerade in der Robotik ist diese Linie oft sehr fein und sehr, sehr schwer zu beantworten, weil man, wenn man nicht bösartig drüber nachdenkt, möglicherweise auch gar nicht drauf kommt, wie zum Beispiel halt so ein Mustererkennungsalgorithmus, den man vielleicht entwickelt hat oder so ein Greifalgorithmus oder so, wie der halt bösartig verwendet werden kann. Aber momentan ist es halt so, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass er bösartig verwendet wird, nahezu 100 Prozent ist, wenn es geht.
Das heißt, du würdest davon abraten, an sowas zu basteln oder?
Na, ich würde schon mir sehr genau überlegen, was ich da tue. Also ob es nicht möglicherweise zum einen Mittel und Wege gibt, solche Dinge so zu entwickeln, dass sie schwerer zu missbrauchen sind. Also unter anderem möglicherweise durch Lizenzen oder durch Eingrenzungen von Forschungsgebieten, dass man sagt, okay, also was wir an dieser Uni entwickeln, darf halt zum Beispiel nicht für kriegerische Zwecke verwendet werden. Das führt nicht dazu, dass Sachen nicht nachvollzogen oder nicht noch mal entwickelt werden, zumindest verzögert. Das ist vielleicht auch helfen kann. Und zum anderen denke ich mal, es ist auch durchaus eine Verantwortung, gerade der Akademiker, die in diesem Bereich unterwegs sind, sich an Maßnahmen zu internationalen Vertragswerken, zur Regulierung von solchen Systemen zu beteiligen, weil die haben die wissenschaftliche Kompetenz, um halt sagen zu können, an welchen Ecken macht es überhaupt Sinn, zum Beispiel mit Regulierung anzufangen? Oder wie kann man denn zum Beispiel versuchen, eine Verifikation aussehen zu lassen, indem man zum Beispiel sagt, okay, jede fliegende Drohne, die so rumfliegt, muss halt irgendwie eine eindeutige Kennung haben, von wem sie gehört und was sie da gerade tut und ähnliche Dinge.
Das könnte man natürlich total geschickt gleich zum nächsten Thema überleiten, nämlich die Drohneanonymisierung einer Waffe. Ich würde aber, bevor wir das machen wollen, erst mal festhalten, also der Wissenschaftler sollte möglicherweise diesmal nicht über der Turmarmast hinterher, sondern vorher drüber nachdenken, was da gebaut wird. Und ich habe jetzt auf der Liste, wo es um die Technik der Drohnen geht, um die Arten noch zwei Starkworte, Killboxes und Double Tap Strikes.
Na, Double Tap Strikes sind eigentlich nicht so richtig Technik, sondern eher eine Anwendung, die ziemlich perfide ist, gerade in den Gebieten Pakistan sind, denen die US-Amerikanischen oder wahrscheinlich US-Amerikanischen Drohnen eingesetzt werden. Die fliegen da Tag und Nacht und haben eine Strategie entwickelt, eine Rakete auf einen Punkt zu feuern, dort Verletzte und Tote zu verursachen. Und dann darauf zu warten, dass Helfer ankommen und dann noch mal zuzuschlagen, kurz danach, um generell das Einander-Helfen dort zu unterminieren.
Aber das erste Mal, als ich von so was gehört habe, war das glaube ich in Bali, wo es diesen Anschlag gab. Wo genau das auch passiert ist. Wo es ja gab einen Einschlag in der Stadt. Und dann irgendwie 20 Minuten später ist genau an dem Unglücksort oder an dem Anschlagsort noch mal eine riesige Bombe explodiert.
Das wurde auch im zweiten Weltkrieg verwendet, in dem Bomben mit unterschiedlich eingestellten Zeitzündern abgeworfen wurden. Also insbesondere die Briten haben sich da hervorgetan. Die haben bei den Bombenangriffen auf deutsche Städte gerne Zeitbomben verwendet, die halt so bis zu 48 Stunden später explodiert sind. Und haben sich teilweise auch angeguckt, wie lange es dauert, bis also Entwarnung gegeben wird. Bis die Leute aus den Bunkern kommen und anfangen aufzuräumen. Und dann die Zeitzünder auf diese Zeiträume eingestellt. Das Parfile an diesem Double Tap ist, was mit den Drohnen ist, dass es halt einen ähnlichen Effekt hat, wie diese Zeitbomben, die darauf abzielen, Feuerwehrleute und Krankenwagen zu erwischen. Weil es dazu führt, dass wenn ein Angriff passiert, wo eine Rakete einschlägt, dass die Leute spätestens nach dem zweiten oder dritten Mal nicht mehr trauen, um dahin zu gehen, den Verletzten zu helfen.
Und bei der Drohne hast du den Vorteil, du kannst halt gucken, wann er am meisten helfen wird. Du musst halt nicht die Uhr einstellen. Hat das noch was mit den Rules of Engagement zu tun?
Die Rules of Engagement werden schon eingehalten, weil die Rules of Engagement sagen, wer sich innerhalb dieses Gebietes befindet, also die sogenannte Killbox, gilt im Zweifel, wenn er tot ist, als Aufständischer.
Das musst du noch mal langsam erklären, wenn sie da schnallt.
Also der Punkt ist, man kann da so eine Drohne natürlich nicht so besonders viel sehen. Man kann halt erkennen, ob jemand irgendein Objekt trägt, was möglicherweise eine Waffe sein könnte oder ob er irgendwelche Dinge umlädt. Aber gerade wenn es nachts ist, dann hat man halt nur Infrarotbilder mit einer relativ beschränkten Auflösung. Und da Drohnen relativ hochfliegen, kann man halt nicht so genau sehen, was jetzt da eigentlich passiert. Du kannst es auf dem Boden und durch ein Nachtsichtgerät nicht wirklich sehen, was da wirklich passiert. Du kannst dann nur Indizien haben, wenn sie längere, kühlere Gegenstände umladen, also möglicherweise Waffen sein können. Also macht man Folgendes, insbesondere die Amerikaner haben halt definiert, dass wer immer männlich und über 14 ist und sich da, wo ein Raketenschlag oder sonstige Militäroperation befindet und dabei getötet oder verletzt wird, kann kein Zivilist sein, sondern muss offensichtlich ein Taliban gewesen sein oder ein sonstiger Al-Qaeda-Terrorist. Er war ja da als die Rakete einschluck und die Rakete wurde ja gegen Terroristen eingesetzt.
Das klingt auf eine sehr perfide Art und Weise logisch. Gibt es denn Berichte aus diesen Ländern?
Ja, da gibt es jetzt einiges an Berichten. Also der bekannteste Geschichte, die gerade auch ein bisschen durch die Medien ging, ist diese Living on a Drones-Studie, die von ein paar sehr renommierten amerikanischen Juristen durchgeführt wurde, die versucht haben, herauszukriegen, wie viele Zivilisten eigentlich zu Tode kommen und welche Auswirkungen hat denn das eigentlich, insbesondere in Pakistan. So andere Berichte, zum Beispiel aus Sudan oder aus Kolumbien, wo auch Drohnen eingesetzt wurden, sind halt ein bisschen sperrlicher. Was unter anderem auch daran liegt, dass die News-Coverage von da sowieso ein bisschen sperrlicher ist. Aber die Berichte aus Pakistan, wenn man die jetzt mal so als Beispiel nimmt, weil doch am meisten passiert, die sind halt schon sehr gruselig. Die gehen halt so weit, dass da ganze Dörfer verlassen werden, weil halt immer wieder was passiert. Und das halt so aus heiterem Himmel kommt. Die Drohnen fliegen halt so hoch und du hörst sie nur, wenn sie tiefer fliegen. Also wenn sie ganz oben an der Oberkante fliegen, hörst du sie halt nicht. Oder sie sind halt auch so weit weg, dass du sie nicht hörst. Und offensichtlich setzen die Amerikaner aber schon ein, dass sie Leute einschüchtern, indem sie halt einfach tiefer fliegen, sodass sie zu hören sind. Und ist dann so, dass in einigen von diesen Gebieten, also in Vaziristan, von halt so örtlichen Dorfbewohnern berichtet wird, dass sie ja so fünf, sechsmal am Tag halt Drohnen hören, weil die halt die ganze Zeit da unterwegs sind, und halt auch richtig viele sind. Und halt permanent was am Himmel ist, und du halt nicht weißt, ob es jetzt eine Drohne ist, die nur guckt, oder eine, die demnächst eine Rakete los schießt. Und das macht die Leute natürlich mürbelnd. Deswegen fliehen sie halt dann auch irgendwann aus den Gebieten.
Das heißt, das ist sozusagen nicht wirklich Kriegsführung, sondern werden quasi zivile Gebiete so als, ja, keine Ahnung. Warum sind gerade in dieser Region so viele Drohnen?
Na, weil die Amerikaner meinen, dass da irgendwie die Al-Qaeda bzw. die Taliban halt ihre Rückzugsräune haben und sich da halt trainieren und aufmunizieren.
Natürlich hinlaufen und Leute entsenden. Also Boots on the ground ist da echt anstrengend. Dort in den Bergen, in diesen Regionen, ist es echt schwer Nachschub hinzubekommen. Und die Locals kennen sich ja deutlich besser aus der Wunderseite mehreren hundert Jahren. Da ist so einmal Drohnen fliegen lassen in so einer Region, die naja, so in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung in der westlichen Welt eher so als, keine Ahnung, Ziegenhirten, keine Ahnung, da wären die Taliban schon die einzigen sein, die man so trifft, wenn man da mit den Drohnen hin und her fliegt. Da kann man halt mit der ganzen Technologie ausprobieren. Es ist gerade als Feind deklariert worden. Man möchte natürlich, es gibt Industrie, die einfach die Drohnen an den Mann bringen möchte. Und die brauchen natürlich immer wieder legitime Einsatzgebiete. Und wenn man dann in irgendeiner Region, wo die Pressecoverage eher gering ist, dann mal da rumspielen kann mit und schauen, wie das so alles funktioniert. Und ob man da auch wirklich in jedes Dorf reinkommt und wie man da vielleicht auch Crowdcontrol von so größeren Mengen Menschen da hinbekommt, dann ist es doch ein perfektes Einsatzgebiet für die Forschung.
Jetzt ist es ja bei allen anderen Waffen davor, dass man immer noch irgendwie sagen konnte, von wem die kommen. Also irgendwie große Bombenangriffe müssen von der Flugzeugflotte, die kommen halt irgendwo her. Selbst eine Atombombe, da gibt es halt nicht so viele. Da wusste man auch genau, wo die kommen. Natürlich in dem Krieg, wenn nicht jemand erschießt, weißt du auch im Zweifel, auch, weil das war. Oder wenn jemand erschossen wird, wenn du das gesehen hast. Jetzt ist es ja bei den Drohnen irgendwie nicht mehr so wirklich gegeben. Ihr redet immer von den Amerikanern. Weiß man wirklich, dass die Amerikaner sind, die die Drohnen haben? Also könnte nicht im Prinzip jeder, weil, naja, es ist halt Technik.
Obama hat sich da dann jetzt geoutet, nachdem er dann ganz stolz erklärt hat, dass er mithilfe der Drohnenflotte auch Osama bin Laden da erlegt hat, war das dann eigentlich auch schon ganz offiziell zugegeben, dass das wirkt. Wir können das und wir haben jetzt bewiesen, dass das auch sehr präzise funktioniert und damit ist schon ganz klar, dass die da zumindest unterwegs sind. Aber auf der anderen Seite hast du natürlich total recht, dass Technologie, die, wenn wir von leasing Drohnen reden, wenn wir von Hardware reden, die eh zu 99% aus China importiert wird, da kann man jetzt irgendwie nachgucken, findet immer dieselben Boards drauf, findet vielleicht Technologie, die irgendwo zusammengeschraubt wird und dann weiterverkauft an so alle Player, die da einfach nur noch Geld auf den Tisch legen, kannst du natürlich dir so als kleiner durchgeknallter Multimilliardär schon deine eigene Drohnenflotte aufbauen. Und am Ende ist selbst wenn dort irgendwelche nicht gekennzeichneten Drohnen, die dann schwer bewaffnet sind durch die Gegend fliegen, überlegst du dir auch dreimal, ob du da jetzt wirklich nah Flugzeuge hinterher schicken möchtest, um die abzuschießen oder ob du dann da mit deinen eigenen Piloten da aufs Spiel setzen möchtest?
Also ich meine, wir haben das ja schon gesehen, jetzt gerade in Libanon, also Israel-Libanon, wo eine Drohne in den israelischen Luftraum eingedrungen ist. Und die Israelis halt auch nicht so richtig wissen, wo die herkommt. Die haben eigenen Angaben zufolge erstmal versucht, den Controlling zu hacken, also um die Drohne zu übernehmen und zu landen. Und haben es wohl aber nicht geschafft, interessanterweise, was sie sehr frustriert hat. Und haben sie dann abgeschossen. Und nehmen sie jetzt halt auseinander und vermuten halt, dass es halt irgendwie die iranischen Ursprungs ist. Aber so richtig beweisen und belegen können sie es halt irgendwie nur anhand von Indizien. Und das wird halt die Norm werden. Also dass Drohnen von Playern kommen, wo halt irgendwie so ein bisschen unklar ist, wo die herkommen, was die der Ursprung ist. Und selbst wenn man weiß, wer die Drohne hergestellt hat, dann ist halt immer noch nicht klar, wer sie eigentlich kontrolliert hat. Also es kann auch eine geklaute Drohne sein oder eine, die irgendwie vom Schwarzmarkt kommt oder die gleichen Dinge mehr. Also das ist halt eine große Bandbreite von Möglichkeiten, weil da eben kein Pilot mehr drin sitzt. Oder kein Fahrer mehr drin sitzt, den man halt im Zweifel befragen oder an seinem Akzent erkennen kann, wo er jetzt ja kommt.
Und auf der anderen Seite ist, wenn du eine asymmetrische Kriegsführung wie jetzt die Vereinigten Staaten da führst gegen vielleicht nicht mal mehr Nationalstaaten, sondern Organisationen, sei es religiös motiviert oder vielleicht wirtschaftlich motiviert, ist ja dann die Antwort auf, sagen wir mal, US-amerikanischem Boden dann auch wieder eine total asymmetrische. Also auch die Flugzeuge da zu 9-11 zu captchern und dort in so Hochhäuser zu lenken, hätte auf eine Art und Weise auch anonym sein können. Also du hättest auch dann komplett den Ursprung verschleiern können. Und dort deine Ziele zu erreichen, indem du jetzt nicht mehr eine Armee vernichten musst, sondern einfach nur noch führende Köpfe, kann natürlich genauso zurückschlagen, dass am Ende man auch als, keine Ahnung, führende wirtschaftliche Persönlichkeit in der westlichen Welt dann plötzlich seine eigene Drohnenverteidigungsarmee braucht, um nicht von der Konkurrenz dort beniede gemacht zu werden oder von...
Da haben wir gerade irgendwie die Standarddrohnen irgendwie, oder die verbreiteten Drohnen haben irgendwie 15 Meter Flügelspannweite und sind halt relativ groß. Das heißt, die werden wahrscheinlich so ein, zwei Millionen kosten. Gibt es da Preise?
Kann man sagen? So eine aktuelle Grey Eagle kostet so zwischen 7 und 8 Millionen etwa.
Okay, die werden wir jetzt nicht zu Hause bauen, aber ich denke jetzt ans andere Ende der Skala, da gibt es halt diese Quadrocopter und so, die natürlich auch in den nächsten Jahren ein bisschen leistungsfähiger werden. Also ist das sozusagen auch eine Entwicklung stattfindet, dass sozusagen ein einzelner oder ein kleines Team, also gar nicht mal der Multimilliardär jetzt, sondern dass ein paar Leute sich so was bauen können?
Also ist halt vollständig absehbar. Die interessante Frage ist halt nur, wird es zu neuen Formen von Terrorismus führen? Meine wahrscheinliche Antwort ist erstmal nicht, weil das Problem halt weniger die Drohne ist als der Sprengstoff. Weil wenn man halt so eine Drohne hat, dann kann man zwar filmen oder irgendjemand erschrecken, aber wenn man nicht den Sprengstoff hat, dann ist da noch lange kein Terrorismus draus geworden. Und wenn man es wollte, dann hätte man auch ohne Drohne im Zweifel da sein Ziel erreichen können, sondern wir können eigentlich davon ausgehen, dass es halt wie mit all diesen Dingen ist, wo immer irgendwie Panik geschwommen wird, gesagt wird, die bösen Terroristen werden es machen. Also was ist hier, was hat man da, Bio Tower zum Beispiel, wo ja auch wieder so ein Klassiker, dass es am Ende halt wieder in ein Spiel der Nationalstaaten bleiben wird, die halt über die entsprechenden Ressourcen verfügen oder halt von ähnlich großen Organisationen, die Großkonzerne oder internationalen Organisationen oder Söldner Firmen und dass solche Akteure sich im Zweifel damit ausrüsten werden. Aber interessant wird halt, gerade im Inneren, wird zum Beispiel auch die Frage, was, wenn die Polizei halt nicht aufhört, bei Quadrocoptern mit Kameras, um halt die Ruhbschrauber zu ersetzen, sondern anfängt halt, nehmen wir mal an, die in fünf Generationen funktionsfähigen, zweieinigen Roboter halt irgendwie mit Trinkgass und Gummiknüppeln auszustatten, um halt Personal zu sparen. Oder halt einfach sehr viel mehr Personal am Ladegerät in der Halle zu haben, für den Fall, dass man es halt mal braucht. Da kommen dann schon interessante Fragen, nämlich, dass eine größere Drohnenarmee ist halt ein enormer Machtmultiplikator, den es so bisher nicht gab. Weil bisher muss man halt immer, gerade jetzt auch wenn man nicht von nicht tödlichen Einsätzen ausgeht, muss man halt immer Menschen überzeugen, dieses zu tun, sei es durch Gehaltszahlen, und sich in Trocknationen und so weiter.
Um uns ganz klar zu sagen, bei den Microwallen hast du auf beiden Seiten Menschen stehen. Und die sind natürlich dann auch dabei, aber die müssen auch dabei sein. Und ein Roboter kannst einfach sagen, lauf da hin und mach.
Also dann halt.
Dann halt, wenn es soweit ist. Über die Konsequenzen und das, was sozusagen zu tun noch kommen könnte, wenn man mit Kriegsmaschinerie, mit semi-autonomer oder autonomer Kriegsmaschinerie zu viel spielt, sprechen wir gleich noch. Jetzt gibt es erstmal auch das Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr.
Live und neu und gut. Wann genau und wo genau?
Fritzee.
Genau.
Cezar, Citizens und Timo Hauer, live von neu und gut, empfohlen von Fritz. Und das hört man um kurze halb zwölf. Nachricht mit Falko Wittich. Nach der tödlichen Prügel-Attacke am Berliner Alexanderplatz sind zwei Tatverdächtige wieder auf freiem Fuß. Das hat die Staatsanwaltschaft mitgeteilt. Der 19- und der 21-Jährige hatten sich gestern der Polizei gestellt. Ein Untersuchungsrichter sah bei dem 19-Jährigen keinen Haftgrund. Für den 21-Jährigen gab es zwar einen Haftbefehl, der wurde aber außer Vollzug gesetzt. Berlins Inn-Senator Henke sagte der Berliner Morgenpost, er sei mit der Entscheidung des Haftrichters unzufrieden und könne sie nicht verstehen. Die beiden Jugendlichen gehören zu einer Gruppe, die für den Tod eines 20-Jährigen verantwortlich gemacht werden. Ein Verdächtiger sitzt derzeit in Untersuchungshaft. Trinkwasser soll langfristig in Berlin um mindestens 15 Prozent billiger werden. Das haben die Regierungsfraktionen von SPD und CDU im Abgeordnetenhaus beschlossen. In dem Beschluss wird der Senat aufgefordert, alle Berliner Wasserkunden bereits in diesem Jahr, um pauschal insgesamt 60 Millionen Euro zu entlasten. Die Grünen nannten die Entlastung unzureichend. Das Bundeskartellamt hatte im Juni verfügt, dass die Berliner Wasserpreise in diesem Jahr deutlich billiger werden müssen. Die syrische Armee will für die Zeit des Islamischen Opferfests alle Militäreinsätze einstellen. Die Waffenruhe solle gemäß dem Vorschlag des UN-Sondergesandten Brahimi von Freitagmorgen an gelten und bis zum Ende der Feiern am Montag dauernd teilte die Armee mit. Die freie syrische Armee, der die meisten Rebellen angehören, erklärte, sie wolle sich ebenfalls an den Waffenstillstand halten. Andere Rebellenführer lehnten einen Waffenstillstand dagegen ab. UN-Generalsekretär Ban forderte Armee und Rebellen in Syrien auf, die Feuerpause tatsächlich einzuhalten. In der Fußball Europa League konnten drei deutsche Mannschaften am Abend Siege feiern. Borussia Mönchengladbach gewann zu Hause gegen Olympique Lyon mit 2 zu 0. Bayer Leverkusen siegte 4 zu 0 bei Rapid Wien und Hannover schaffte in Schweden einen 2 zu 1 Sieg gegen Helsingborg. Der VfB Stuttgart kam gegen den FC Kopenhagen nicht über ein 0 zu 0 Unentschieden hinaus.
Wetter.
Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen, wir haben derzeit in Berlin-Dalem 7 Grad, Prenzlberg meldet 8 Grad. In Angermünde und Neuropäen sind es 6 Grad, in Potsdam, Cottbus, Frankfurt und Wittenberge 7 Grad. In der Nacht weniger Wolken, es bleibt meist trocken. Tieftemperaturen liegen im Bereich von plus 3 bis minus 1 Grad. Am Tage dann im Süden teilweise wolkig, ansonsten heiter. Und es bleibt meist trocken bei maximal 5 bis 8 Grad. Stadtverkehr Berlin. Da haben wir die A100 in Richtung Wedding an einigen Stellen. Derzeit auf dem Stadtring Stau oder stockender Verkehr. Die A115 zwischen dem Kreuz Zehendorf und Spanischer Lehe. Da ist die Richtungsfahrbahn gesperrt wegen einer Baustelle bis 6 Uhr. Außerdem auf der Avus statt einwärts zwischen Spanischer Lehe und Hüttenweg ist derzeit nur eine spurfreie Stau haben wir ab Kreuz Zehendorf. A111 statt Autobahn statt einwärts. Bis morgen früh 5 Uhr Vollsperrungen zwischen Weidmanns-Lusterdam und am Festplatz. Gegen Mitternacht beginnt die Sperrung dann sogar noch ein Stück früher. Und zwar bereits an der Schulzendorfer Straße. Marzahn, die Hellersdorfer Straße statt auswärts zwischen alter Hellersdorfer Straße und Rieserstraße besteht nach einem Unfall Staugefahren. In Mitte gibt es Filmarbeiten, deswegen bis 6 Uhr morgen früh in der Kronenstraße zwischen Glinkerstraße und Charlottenburg. Sperrung der Straße in beiden Richtungen. Die A24 haben wir dann noch in Richtung Hamburg. Zwischen Dreigwittstockdorfer und Tankstelle Stolpe ist derzeit ein Schwertransport unterwegs, den ihr leider nicht überholen könnt. Und zum Schluss zur S-Bahn. Es gibt eine Signalstörung in Pankow-Heinersdorf. Deswegen auf den Linien S1, S2 und S8 Verspätungen und Teilausfälle. Die Linie S8, die verkehrt derzeit nur zwischen Zeuten Grünau und Kreisweiler Straße.
Gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn ihr einen ganz bestimmten Song aus der Fritz-Playlist sucht, dann seht sie euch doch einfach an.
Die Playlist auf fritz.de. Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Heute Chaosradio im Blue Moon zu Gast Rob Erdgeist und Frank. Hallo und willkommen zurück. Und wir haben jetzt noch nicht mal mehr eine halbe Stunde, um das Ganze zum Abschluss zu bringen, weil wir heute geredet haben. Das sind Kriegsmaschinen, autonome Kriegsmaschinen, also die sagen, die im Zweifel auch selbst denken soll, auch bekannt als Drohnen. Wir haben schon beschrieben die Geschichte der Wissenschaft, die dem Militär hilft, was Drohnen sind, wie sie funktioniert, wo sie eingesetzt werden. Und jetzt müssten wir eigentlich mal zu den Konsequenzen kommen. Also was genau wird uns da blühen in Zukunft mit diesen Kriegsmaschinen, die quasi keinen menschlichen Einsatz mehr brauchen?
Naja, wir müssen uns ein bisschen überlegen, welche Rolle der nicht Frieden oder Krieg in der zukünftigen Politik spielen wird. Und zumindest unsere momentanen Regierenden sind ja offensichtlich der Meinung, dass es immer wichtiger wird, dass sie halt in der Lage sein sollen, Einsätze irgendwo auf der Welt zu führen, wo gerade mal wieder Öl gefunden wurde. Oder irgendwie seltene Erden oder sonstige Dinge, die sie halt gerne hätten. Unser nächster Krieg, an dem die Bundeswehr auch teilnehmen soll, ist ja in Mali. Was ist da los? Also, worum es geht, ist wohl da die Befriedung der umliegenden Gegenden, weil da halt mal wieder islamistische Terroristen oder Leute, die als solche bezeichnet werden, unterwegs sein sollen. Worum es da eigentlich geht, habe ich mir noch nicht so genau angeguckt. Ich vermute mal, der Kontext, in dem der Bundesverteidigungsminister auch Waffenhäfte drohend forderte, ist dann eben auch genau so was, dass man sagen kann, wir müssen da keine Soldaten hinschicken und wir können also Einsätze fahren, bei denen wir als Bundeswehr oder als Bundesrepublik auch tödliche Gewalt ausüben können, ohne dass wir eigene Soldaten riskieren.
Das lässt sich ja im Inland bestimmt super verkaufen.
Genau, also da ist es halt auch interessant, so wenn man sich so die Kommentare anguckt. Ich hatte in einer VZ einen Artikel darüber geschrieben und bei vielen Kommentaren war da so, ja, aber es ist doch total super. So irgendwie wollen wir doch haben, dann können wir irgendwie endlich mal wieder da irgendwie unterwegs sein, ohne als Militär, ohne dass wir da irgendwie Soldaten in Buddybacks nach Hause bringen müssen. Und genau diese Art Einstellung wird halt dazu führen, dass es halt mehr Drohnen, mehr Drohnen einzugeben. Das zweite große Thema ist Grenzsicherung. Wir leben ja in einer Welt, wo bedingt durch Klimawandel und andere politische Veränderungen immer mehr Leute woanders hinwollen. Also sei es nun halt, dass sie von Mexiko und die Vereinigten Staaten wollen, oder dass sie von Nordafrika nach Europa wollen, oder von Südosteuropa nach EU-Europa. Klar ist halt diese Grenzen, wenn man die verteidigen will, dann wird es ganz schön schnell ganz schön hässlich. Also was wir da gesehen haben an der innerdeutschen Grenze, also mit Mauer und Stacheldraht und den damals relativ primitiven Selbstschussanlagen, die im Wesentlichen aus einer Patrone Hackschrot und einem Draht bestanden, der, wenn ein Draht berührt wurde, diese Hackschrot-Schießanlage ausgelöst hat. Und wenn man sich so mal zurückguckt, was das für ein riesiges Thema war, also wenn man so alte Spiegel anguckt oder so, diese Selbstschussanlagen war über Jahre hinweg das große Thema in der innerdeutschen Verhandlerei und Politik. Und dann gucken wir uns halt mal zum Beispiel Israel die Grenzen zum Grasastreifen oder zum Libanon an oder die nordkoreanische, südkoreanische Grenze und demnächst dann wohl auch die mexikanische, amerikanische, äusseramerikanische Grenze und da werden Systeme eingesetzt, die quasi autonom gesteuerte Maschinengewehre sind. Wie funktioniert das? Es funktioniert so, dass momentan da halt auch noch ein Mensch in der Loop ist, also halt noch ein Mensch, der Tötungsentscheidungen treffen soll. Das heißt also man hat da Sensoren, die sagen, okay in diesem Grenzabschnitt versucht gerade jemand drüber zu kommen. Sei es über geotektronische Sensoren, die Erschütterungen im Erdboden erfassen, über Kameras, Bewegungsmelder und solche Dinge und Millimeterradar und dann wird ein Maschinengewehrturm mit Kameras da hingerichtet, wo die Sensoren gesagt haben, da ist was, fährt dann genau auf diese Person der Personengruppe rein und alarmiert einen Operator und sagt, hier habe ich was. So und dann kann der halt entscheiden zu schießen oder erstmal einen Warnschluss abzugeben oder zu sagen Hände hoch auf den Boden legen oder was auch immer oder halt auf Full-Auto stellen und Full-Auto heißt halt irgendwie identifiziertes Ziel wird halt einfach erschossen. Und die Südkoreaner bauen ähnliche Systeme, die mobil sind, also die halt rumfahren sollen in Grenzabschnitten, in die sie jetzt nachdem es da die ersten Medienberichte gab vor ein paar Jahren und die Leute meinten so, naja so richtig toll ist es ja nicht, jetzt Logik einbauen, um zu erkennen, ob der, denjenigen, den sie da angetroffen, angerufen haben, seine Hände hebt, um sich zu ergeben. Und dann wird halt der Roboter halt den Gefangenen machen. Und solche Systeme, die halten, sagen wir mal Menschen, denen die Last abnehmen, halt auf unbewaffnete Flüchtlinge zu schießen, darum geht es ja meistens an Grenzen, die, denke ich mal, werden sich doch stark verbreiten.
Es ist dann auch spannend, ob der dann mitbekommt, dass so der Krieg vorbei ist oder die Grenze jetzt da gar nicht mehr existiert. Oder ob dann, wie die japanischen Soldaten auf den Inseln nach dem zweiten Weltkrieg, dann da noch plötzlich in irgendwelchen längst befriedigten Gebieten, du da von Roboter und Hobbs genommen wirst, die der Meinung sind, da jetzt Leute noch zusammentreiben zu müssen. So, was ja eigentlich spannend ist, ist, dass es ja, es sind ja am Ende auch wieder Computer. Es sind ja auch am Ende wieder dieselben Dinge, die bei dir zu Hause hässliche Bluescreens machen. Es sind genau dieselben Dinge, denen du jetzt auch noch irgendwelchen KI-Algorithmen anvertraust, solche Entscheidungen generell zu treffen. Es sind Tötungsmaschinen, die über Rückkanäle, die eventuell manipulierbar sind, über mehrere tausend Kilometer noch mal Rückfrage halten, zuweilen, die durch technische Manipulation vor Ort eventuell übernommen werden können. Wo du eine Telepräsenz dorthin dir durch diese Tötungsmaschine versuchst zu geben, wo du nicht mehr weißt, ob das jetzt wirklich alles der Realität entspricht. Ich bekomme ein Fernsehbild von dem, was diese Maschine denkt, was jetzt die Realität ist. Und die aktuelle Drohnenforschung geht dir dahin, dass die Algorithmen dieser künstlichen Intelligenzen den Menschen wieder nachweisen müssen, wie sie jetzt zu dieser Entscheidung gekommen sind. Warum sie glauben anhand welcher Parameter, dass das, was da im Sichtfeld ist, jetzt ein Terrorist ist, damit der Mensch diese Entscheidung nachvollziehen kann. Weil es wirklich ein großes Problem ist, dass was dir präsentiert wird am Monitor, ob du dem da einfach so vertraust und dann draufhältst oder ob dir was vorgegaukelt wird. Den Sensoren einer Drohne oder eines Killroboters kann man vielleicht durch ein vorgehaltenes Videobild sonst was vormachen und dann läuft da halt nur, keine Ahnung, eine harmlose Familie lang während der Operator da, der nur die Sensoren, der der Drohne hat, glaubt, der müsste jetzt los schlagen.
Gibt es denn Beispiele schon oder Berichte von Drohnenhacks?
Ich hatte gerade schon von der Geschichte aus Israel erzählt, wo die Israelis versucht haben, diese vermutete Iranische bzw. von einer Hisbollah gestellte Drohne zu übernehmen, was ihnen wohl nicht so ganz gelungen ist. Die Iraner haben behauptet, dass sie eine amerikanische Drohne, eine amerikanische Stelsdrohne gehackt und übernommen haben, wo eigentlich nicht ganz klar ist, ob das der Realität entspricht oder ob sie die mit anderen Mitteln runtergeholt haben. Klar ist jedenfalls, dass sie sie eingefangen haben und in der Turnhalle präsentieren konnten. Und es gibt auch vereinzelte Berichte aus den Konflikten, also Georgien und Abhazien, zumindest von mehr- oder minder erfolgreichen Versuchen, Drohnen zu übernehmen. Am Ende ist halt immer die Frage, wie viel Aufwand man da reinsteckt und wie gut halt die Absicherung der Kanäle, also der Steuerkanäle ist. Aber eben auch die Frage, wie gut ist dann eigentlich die Absicherung der Kontrollzentren? Man hat halt in den Drohnen-Kontrollzentren in den USA ganz normale Malware, also normale Viren gefunden, die sich da einfach eingefangen haben beim Games-Zocken auf ihren Windows-Computern, auf denen sie halt nebenbei dann halt auch ihre Drohnen geflogen haben.
Ich schlage mir gerade mit der Hand ins Gesicht.
Ja, und diese Frage des Übernehmens von Drohnen und der Kontrolle von Drohnen wird dann halt akut, wenn die Amerikaner mal gegen einen ernstzunehmenden Gegner antreten müssen. Also wenn sie halt gegen Iran oder China oder Russland tatsächlich aktiv werden und die auch so über eigene Drohnen verfügen, als auch über entsprechende Einheiten, die durchaus in der Lage sind, schlecht gesicherte Systeme zu übernehmen. Und da wird es dann halt interessant. Und die Frage halt, wie viel Autonomie brauchen wir in Drohnen, wird durch, wenn der Gegner auch Drohnen hat, unmittelbar verschärft. Weil man natürlich, wenn ein Computer eine Drohne steuert, dann ist er halt sehr viel schneller als ein Mensch. Der kann sehr viel schneller Entscheidungen treffen, auf sehr viel mehr Input reagieren, muss nicht erst Abwägungen treffen und den Anwalt fragen, ob er los schlagen kann.
Aber kommen wir nicht da zu einem Punkt, wo man sagen kann, möglicherweise sind die Drohnen doch was Gutes, weil man irgendwann den Menschen ganz rausnehmen kann und dann treten nur noch Drohnen gegeneinander an?
Naja, das wird eben interessant, die Frage, wie sieht dann eine Welt aus, in der sich Drohnen gegenseitig bekämpfen? Gucken wir denn nur noch zum Himmel und sehen, dass da irgendwie Roboter am Himmel sind, die sich gegenseitig bekriegen und gelegentlich runterfallen und dabei brennen? Oder wird eigentlich das Ziel weiter sein, Herrschaft über die Menschen auf dem Boden zu erringen? Oder sie dazu zu bringen, Dinge zu tun oder nicht zu tun? Also was ist eigentlich das Ziel von militärischer Auseinandersetzung dann?
Also sagen Sie, ein Science-Fiction-Szenario jetzt. Ne, achso, ja. Also was ich mir vorstelle ist, die Menschen eines Landstriches, also wo es da meinetwegen auch um Rohstoffe geht oder so, die arbeiten auf der Fölle in die Rohstoffe und der Drohnenkampf entscheidet halt, wo die Rohstoffe hingeliefert werden. Also quasi. Das wäre doch sozusagen eine sehr effektive...
Warum denn nicht gleich Drohnen und die Rohstoffe abbauen lassen?
Dann würden wir uns quasi selber überflüssig machen.
Oh super. Aber trotzdem gibt es ja dann Entscheider. Es gibt ja immer exponierte Persönlichkeiten in allen Gesellschaften, die anzugreifen, deutliche Lohnen da ist als jetzt nur, naja, so irgendwie Joe von der Straße anzugreifen. Und gegen die wird sich dann im Zweifel der Krieg dann eher noch richten. Dass man sich wirklich explizit Entscheider dahernimmt und versucht, durch das Bestrafen von Einzelnen oder durch das Töten von Einzelnen eine andere Gesellschaft komplett zu übernehmen. Das ist ja immer möglich. Also einfach nur Drohnen des Gegners zu bekämpfen, ist ja nun noch kein inherenter Wert an sich. Meistens hast du ja nicht einen Zwist mit dem Drohnen deines Opponenten, sondern mit wirklich den Führern oder Teilen der Bevölkerung.
Ja, aber das ist doch super, dann sperren wir die Führer mit ihren Drohnen auf ein eingesperrtes Areal und dann erledigt sich der Recht von selbst.
Also es gibt da einen schönen Stanislaw Lem-Roman, den ich bei dieser Gelegenheit mal den Hörern als Herz legen möchte. Das heißt, der Flop ist ein Roman aus der Ion Tiri-Reihe, der also doch eigentlich mit so zu den besten Werken von Lem zählt. Und da ist das Szenario so, dass die Menschheit, der Kriege überdrüssig geworden, beschlossen hat, dass sie ihr gesamtes Waffenarsenal auf den Mond verlagert, also dass jeder Staat bekommt auf dem Mond ein abgestecktes Areal und in dem kann er vorautomatische Waffenfabriken unterbringen. Und der Mond wird zur Toten Zone erklärt, also es gibt halt keine Kommunikation mit diesen Waffenfabriken auf dem Mond. Und wenn irgendein Staat sagt, er will jetzt aber seine Waffen haben, dann erfahren alle anderen Staaten auch davon. Also dann können die halt auch sagen, sie wollen ihre Waffen haben. Und das geht halt eine ganze Weile gut so. Und ja, das ist halt irgendwie paradiesisch und friedlich. Aber irgendwann wird dann halt den Leuten so ein bisschen mulmig, weil sie halt wissen wollen, ob sie dann zum einen haben sie denn jetzt eigentlich noch Waffen da oben oder haben die evolutionären Algorithmen, die da oben jetzt rumwirkeln, irgendwas anderes beschlossen? Ich will jetzt mal nicht den Plot spoilern. Jedenfalls schicken sie dann halt ihren Tee-Rider hoch, der mal nachgucken soll, was denn jetzt eigentlich los ist. Und genau dieses Szenario ist natürlich wieder ein Name indiziert des Buches der Flop, es ist halt natürlich schief gegangen. Aber es ist sehr lesenswert, weil man dieses Szenario mal in aller Tiefe, insbesondere halt auch in den Auswirkungen von künstlicher Intelligenz, von einem der besten Sci-Fi Autoren, die wir jetzt so hatten, durchgespielt lesen will.
So jetzt haben wir, sagen wir zum Thema, gibt es eigentlich noch zwei wichtige Fragen. Die eine ist, jetzt habt ihr sehr viel in den vergangenen zwei Stunden zu Drohnen erzählt und auch wenn das eine schöne Vorstellung ist, vermute ich, dass ihr nicht im Operationszentrum der Amis wart und sozusagen die Drohnen da selber auseinander genommen habt. Was sind Informationsquellen, wenn man sich selber zu diesem Thema informieren will?
Es gibt eine Menge in der Presse dazu. Da muss man natürlich sehr sorgfältig lesen, weil viel davon halt durchaus auch einfach Propaganda ist. Es gibt jetzt gerade im Kontext des amerikanischen Wahlkampfs und des damit zusammenhängenden, auf die Brust, Trommels der Amerikaner über die Tötung von Bin Laden einiges an Sachen, die da so berichtet werden in der Weiheit, also beziehungsweise Weiheit online. Gibt es immer wieder relativ ausführliche Berichte zu Drohnen, Drohntechnologie und Entwicklungen, die halt auch sehr, naja, sagen wir, meteorisch und industriell komplex zentrisch sind. Ansonsten gibt es bei globalsecurity.org, das ist eine NGO, die sich halt mit diesen Themen beschäftigt was. Und ansonsten gibt es die International Campaign Against Robotic Arms, also die Kampagne gegen Kriegsroboter, die aus der Kampagne gegen Landminen hervorgegangen ist in Großbritannien. Die haben sehr ausführliche Informationsseiten und so, die auch die wissenschaftliche, also den wissenschaftlichen Zweig davon betrachten. Ansonsten gibt es, um so den Stand der Technik so ein bisschen abzuwägen und wohin die gerade gehen, gibt es die, glaube ich auch Glow Security, hatte eine Studie freigekämpft von den Amerikanern. Die heißt Autonomie in DoD Systems, also Autonomität in Systemen des Verteidigungsministeriums der Amerikaner, wo sie auf 160 Seiten dieses ganze Problem auswalzen, was sie haben, wie sie Drohnen einsetzen wollen, welche Doktrin sie haben, was die Fähigkeiten sind, wo sie hinwollen, was so die unterschiedlichen Grad an Autonomität sein sollen, wie die Bewaffnung aussehen soll und wovor sie so Angst haben. Und da stehen ein paar sehr erstaunliche Dinge drin, unter anderem, dass die größte Furcht, die sie haben, sind natürlich die Chinesen. Also schreiben sie natürlich nicht so, aber sie reden halt von einem Potential Enemy, also einem potentiellen Feind, der möglicherweise Drohnen bauen könnte, die halt keine Hemmungen haben, also die halt keine Kriegsrechtseinschränkungen haben. Und da sagen sie, okay, da kann man sich dann eigentlich nur mit anderen Drohnen dagegen verteidigen, weil der Mensch ist halt nicht schnell genug dafür. Das heißt, wir befinden uns schon auf so einem Rennen nach unten aus Frucht, dass der andere radikaler sein könnte beim Einsatz von Autonomie. Das ist dann durchaus eine lesenswerte Sache. Ansonsten, was das Handfiction angeht, Daniel Suarez hat ein Buch geschrieben, Kill Decision ist jetzt so literarisch nicht sein bestes, aber auf jeden Fall, was jetzt so die Zukunftsszenarien angeht, von autonomen Drohenschwermen doch sehr plastisch und sehr eindrücklich und eindringlich, kann man doch durchaus lesen auch.
Dann kann man sich da weiterbilden, wie ist jetzt, also was machen wir jetzt damit? Also ich meine, für Vorratssatenspeicherung oder Akta oder was, da kann man auch so sagen, Massen symbolisieren, hat man jetzt zu sagen, habt ihr da irgendwie sozusagen so eine Bürgerpflicht, die ihr kompliziert, so über Drohnen muss man auch aufpassen, oder ist das sowas, da steht man eher neben, guckt sich das an, dann kann man ja nix machen.
Na ja, am Ende sind Drohnen, die in unserem Namen durch die Gegend fliegen, am Ende müssen die genauso demokratisch legitimiert werden wie Bundeswehreinsätze im Ausland. Und natürlich hat man da als Bürger erst mal die Pflicht, sich zu informieren. Man soll mal dahergehen und schauen, was die Entwicklung ist. Wenn wir Wehrpflichtige haben, die Wehrpflichtarmee extra als Bürger in Uniform konzipiert worden, damit da noch Leute mit Gewissen durch die Gegend marschieren, die dann vielleicht vor dem Mord noch mal nachdenken, ist es bei Drohnen und bei dem kompletten Outsourcing, dieser Entscheidung an irgendeinen Algorithmus, dann vielleicht dann uns zu informieren und zu schauen, ob wir das wollen?
Also konkret denke ich, mal geht es gerade darum zu verhindern, dass die Bundeswehr ohne weitere Reflexe und Bewachtete Drohnen bekommt. Und man auf jeden Fall da klare Beschränkungen einziehen muss, die sagen, der Einsatz militärischer Gewalt, auch wenn er von Drohnen ausgeht, kann nicht in so einem unregulierten Grauzonenbereich stattfinden. Insbesondere nicht in so einem Bereich wie Somatand, die CAA tut. Die Frage, die sich danach anschließt, ist natürlich, inwieweit ist Deutschland als führendes Rüstungsexportland? Und wie streben sie an, gerade auch bei Drohnenführen zu werden? Inwieweit will man sich persönlich daran beteiligen? Sei es im Rahmen von Universitäts- und sonstigen Forschungsprojekten oder durch Wahl seines Arbeitgebers möchte man an solchen Technologien teilnehmen? Oder möchte man lieber sagen, okay, da hab ich jetzt keine Lust drauf? Und auch wenn da Search and Rescue dransteht, dann erlaube ich mir trotzdem mal zu hinterfragen, was eigentlich mit dieser Technologie jetzt passiert.
Eine Anführung in Kriegsmaschinen haben wir euch in vergangenen zwei Stunden gegeben. Wir haben natürlich nicht alles geschafft, aber ich glaube, es war ein Rundumblick über das Thema und ihr habt jetzt auch gehört, wo ihr euch nochmal genauer darüber informieren könnt. Es wird natürlich auch ein Podcast zu dieser Sendung geben, wo man das alles nochmal genau nachhören kann. Sobald Chaosradio.de wieder am Start ist, wird er auch dort verfügbar sein. Hier auf Fritz wird es ihn auf jeden Fall noch in dieser Nacht geben. Vielen Dank allen Beteiligten für die interessanten Einblicke. Möchte ich das jetzt wirklich sagen. Und zum Abschluss der Sendung noch ein paar Goodies, die sozusagen mit dem Umfeld zu tun haben, indem wir uns hier bewegen, nämlich dem Chaosradio, des Chaos Computer Clubs. Da soll ja möglicherweise gegen Ende des Jahres möglicherweise eine Veranstaltung stattfinden. Ist das korrekt?
Die findet nicht nur möglicherweise statt, die findet ziemlich sicher zwischen dem 27. und 30. Dezember statt. Diesmal abweichend in Hamburg. Wir haben, nachdem das BCC in Berlin für den Ansturm zu klein geworden ist, das Haus CCH, den Kongress Center Hamburg, gemietet und werden dort dann zu den üblichen Zeiten zwischen den Jahren Wiederhacker aus aller Welt erwarten. Wir haben gerade 290 Vortragseinreichungen, von denen wir knapp 100 auswählen. Das spricht dann schon mal für Qualität in den Vorträgen. Und wir haben diesmal Platz. Das heißt, dass viele Leute, die in den letzten Jahren gar nicht erst versucht haben, ein Ticket zu besorgen, dieses Jahr doch beruhigt dort. Es gibt Tickets. Es gibt Tickets und keine Ticketlotterie.
Also Vorträge habt ihr jetzt schon, da kann man nichts mehr einreichen. Wenn man da irgendwie mitmachen will, gibt es da noch Möglichkeiten?
Ja, natürlich. Wir haben mit den neuen Möglichkeiten ein Haus, was wir so noch nie bespielt haben. Mit all den Risiken, aber auch mit den Möglichkeiten, die man so hat. Wir wollen dieses Jahr ausprobieren, mal das Konzept einer Assembly, was so ungefähr wie ein Village auf einem Camp funktionieren soll. Das heißt, in den letzten Jahren ging der Trend eher so dahin, dass das Hackcenter, was ja so ursprünglich der größte Anteil beim Kongress gewesen ist, wo man in seiner Community zusammensaß und mal auch an einem Projekt gehackt hat, wenn man sich sonst das Jahr über nicht gesehen hat, das ist ja ein bisschen in den Hintergrund getreten. Der Fokus hat sich mehr auf den Besuch der Vorträge verschoben. Wir wollen dieses Jahr mit den Assemblies versuchen, wieder Communities anzulocken, die sich zusammensetzen sollen, die auch als Anlaufstelle für Interessierte dort fungieren. Und die bekommen dann, wenn sie sich vorher anmelden, doch schon ziemlich entspannten Platz zu weihen, sogar am Fenster zugewiesen. Und sollen dann...
Versprich nicht zu viel.
Sollen natürlich auch vorher die Werbetrommel rühren, dass sie dort als Ansprechpartner für ihr Projekt da sind, dass sie dort auch selber dann wieder eine Art Homebase haben für ihre Community, was in den letzten Jahren aus Platzgründen immer schwieriger geworden ist.
Okay, da gibt es also viel Platz, den ihr auch noch selber erfüllen könnt. Wenn ich dahin will, wo kann ich da informationsmäßig so?
Das Kongress-Wiki ist gestern online gegangen. Und unter Events.ccc.de gibt es rechts so einen Link in dieses Wiki. Das ist ziemlich einfach zu finden.
Und da sonst noch Informationen zu, wie es mit den Assemblies gemeint ist, wo es Karten gibt und Hotels und dergleichen Dinge mehr. Am besten Events.ccc.de, da findet ihr alle Informationen.
Genau, und der 29c3 dieses Jahr findet unter dem Motto Not My Department statt, was eine Referenz an Werner von Braun ist, der paraphrasiert, nachdem er gefragt worden ist, warum er mit den Nazis kollaboriert hat, um dort Raketen herzustellen, mit denen Menschen getötet worden sind und warum er der Zwangsarbeiter aus den KZ eingesetzt hat, gemeint hat, dass ich bin doch nur Wissenschaftler und ich sorge eigentlich nur dafür, dass die Raketen in die Luft kommen, aber wo sie landen, das ist nicht mein Metier, das ist Not My Department.
Die Chaosradio Sendung, die heute stattfindet, also quasi bekommt ein viertägiges Kongresseeignis in Hamburg dieses Jahr. Vielen Dank euch noch mal, vielen Dank euch fürs Zuhören. Ich übergebe jetzt an Henrik Schröder, der euch hier Punk-Musik um die Ohren hauen wird, bis sie bluten vielleicht, vielleicht auch ein bisschen. Vielleicht weiß ich es nicht genau, aber er wird es euch bestimmt gleich selber sagen. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter und ich habe nur noch eine wichtige Nachricht für euch. Macht immer schön eure Backups und lasst euch nicht überwachen.